what
thanks Tara
good evening and welcome to this
District planning committee meeting on
Thursday the 14th of June 2023
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I
am the chairman of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on on your microphones
and turn it off when you're finished
that will be indicated by the red light
at the top
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and as concise as possible and if
any members May or wish to remove a
jacket if because of the extreme heat
please feel free
agenda at number two apologies for
absence Tara may I have a apologies for
absence please
councilor Bell's in the chamber
Council White please
I'm not a missed if there'd been um
called or not but counselor within and
cancer label and like to give their
apologies please yeah thank you we got
that thank you very much indeed
councilor white uh we moved to a gender
item three which is the minutes it is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 16th of February
2023 which are found on pages 7 to 30 of
the agenda pack are approved as a true
and accurate record ISO moved do I have
a second ever that motion please
counselor stamp thank you any member
wish to raise any issues or should we
agree by sin
agreed thank you members
agenda Isom number four which is
Declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regards to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting do I have any declarations
please members
Tara can confirm that there are no
declarations
thank you we move on to a gender item
number five which is a reference two two
zero one one seven four o u t m that's
Land north of the Groves Burnham Road
Lexington we move to this agenda item
which is found on pages 31-76 on the
agenda pack members there has been a
member update in relation to this item
of business the officer presents in the
application and the report is Mr Michael
Johnson Mr Johnson would you please
present the report
thank you
thank you chairman
the um the members update really so a
correction
to the application in terms of the
representations received in the report
at 7.4.1 it states uh 50 consultations
were received that was an error uh and
in actual threat there was 166
representations received and also just
to state that the report does take
account of all the dog representations
thank good chip
okay
um
if we start this application is an
outline planning application with all
matters reserved except for the means of
access from steeple Road and Burnham
Road
this is for residential development of
up to 160 dwellings including affordable
housing uh five percent of the dwellings
being bungalows 100 square meters of
Office hub floor space
um 0.21 of land for a children's day
nursery and Associated parking
use Class E of the plan and use classes
order Community Park sustainable Urban
drainage system and Associated
infrastructure we just will take you
through the slides there's quite there's
quite a lot of slides
um so I'll sort of try to run through
them fairly quickly and just sort of
highlight what's stated on the on the
plans obviously at any point later on we
want to come back and touch on any
particular wishes on the plan we can do
so
so um so my college will just start with
the with the first slide and I'll just
run through what it contains and then
we'll just move on to the next one at
the end of that we'll just have a bit of
a summary of the officer's report and
then we can take the debate from there
foreign
right
um this is just uh outline the site
boundary
um
adjacent to but outside the Eastern edge
of the defined settlement boundary for
legend
the site is not the subject of
international or local landscape
designations but it's approximately 10
hectares in sight
okay
this is an area of photograph just to
give the site context
um you may not be able to read the
annotations on there but just but they
cover
um well they showed that these sites uh
it's predominantly a flat site
rectangular in shape
um comprised of two agricultural Fields
south of steeple Road and North of
Burnham Road and include some native
hedgerows boundary trees and ditches
detached dwellings bound bounded by
mature Hedges lied to the South and to
the West uh are more modern residential
developments currently on the edge of
the village
there is consented residential
development that's down in the south
west crawler you can see that um uh
which my colleague has highlighted there
with the cursor
um we've got the primary school in
relation to the site King George
Plainfield Parish Hall and the church
let's move to the next slide
now this just sets out the local
facilities and services we've got petrol
station convenience store and post
office Supermarket Red Lion Pub Primary
School Parish Hall Motel King George
Plainfield
um I do appreciate that most of you may
well know these facilities but it's just
necessary to just to highlight what
these are
um site features planned
um
uh contouring a public right-of-way
ponds watercourses and flood risk areas
listed Builders and Heritage assets gas
infrastructure trees rear boundaries to
adjacent properties vehicle and
pedestrian access Heights of adjacent
buildings again I do appreciate that
you'd not be able to see the legend
clearly at all
um but it just sort of generally sets
out in any elaboration again I will pick
up one later on
so the next slide is what is called the
framework plan
[Music]
um
again it just shows the access points
the scheme is predominantly a two-story
development
um and there was also an area for single
story development those would be the
Bungalows as mentioned in the
description
um there's a proposed five meter wide
landscape buffer zone to adjacent to
adjacent properties
and there's a proposed public open space
which lies to the Eastern edge of the
site
okay
so this next slide just sets out an
illustrative master plan now this is
just Illustrated first for for
purposes of us showing how a development
can be
constructed on the site it's not a
definitive plan but it gives us an
outline in terms of the the access roads
the orientation of the development so
for example on the on the western
Ballinger we can see rear Gardens are
button onto the common boundary with
existing residential development again
it shows out you know the public open
space as we said before
Etc and other facilities provided within
the development
again if there's any questions we can
come back on that later on
uh slide nine
again just showing Burnham Road access
and a general Arrangement
um is a plan submitted for our Highway
Engineers comments in in terms of the
appropriateness of the site for
Behavioral access
and slide 10 again just so in the
opposite end of the site from steeple
road again the site access and
connectivity Arrangements
does it again set out there
okay slide 11.
um again these are just matters of
details just showing visibility displays
just to show that the the site can be
developed to provide appropriate access
for vehicles exiting the site
um sliding 12 is a training strategy
um 13 is an illustrative Urban form plan
again it's a bit more of the same you
can sort of move on from that one
and here we've got indicative cross
sections just showing the relationship
of
again the indicative dwellings and how
they relate to existing dwellings so on
the top we can see on the on the left
hand side there's a existing dwelling
um
and we show that the distances the
back-to-back distances the rear facades
of facing dwellings being in that
particular case uh up to 50 meters which
I'm planning terms it well it exceeds
our standards in terms of overlooking
again we've got this illustrative Street
types and characteristics again as I
said this is indicative should the
application be supported any reserved
matters would drilled down into the
finer details of of how these would look
okay that's the again the proposed
public open space
over there I think we can move on from
that one
now this one just shows the the The
Walking routes the connections to the
public
um
open rights of way
for the HRA that would be for the
habitats
um
assessment
again just showing the possibilities
that are proposed there normally mainly
around the North and the and the
southern of the site how it can access
facilities Etc
again this is sustainability just
showing the site in its context
um how it relates to some of the
existing facilities which were mentioned
earlier
and we've got site photographs here
showing the different perspectives
um I think I'll just
floating to my plan here just to show
the orientations
I think we've got
[Music]
um
the first one that's from
that's from that's from Burnham super
roads there
again just looking across the site we
can see the existing residential
development over
over to the Eastern side the western
side
apologies it's a bit small even for me
to see from here
um and if we just pan through again just
really given the vistas of the site
showing it in context that's the
um the recent residential development
over in the south west on the side uh
bottom which is a closer photograph of
that
can be familiar with the area abuse
towards cycling Burnham Road looking
West
okay views of sight from steeple Road
Northern access
again just to give a flavor of the site
okay
um so that's the
presentation slides we can always go
back to any one of the size if any more
detail is required I think it does have
the maybe the illustrative master plan I
think that that's a useful one to to
rest on for now
um so summary and conclusions Lexington
is considered to be a sustainable
location for new development
and although outside of the defined
development boundary The Proposal is
judged to be sustainable development
through the three-dimension test of the
national plenum policy framework
and that's in terms of the economic
considerations we have the Office hub
children nursery and construction jobs
from uh any any approved development
social significant contribution to the
supply of housing in the district and
maintenance of a five-year housing Line
supply
160 new homes of which 64 will be
affordable that creates around 40
percent
uh and a significant amount of new
public open space
environmental clearly there will be some
impact on the character and setting of
the town but in office's view this is
limited provided the principles set out
in the master plan and the terms of the
106 and requirements of the recommended
conditions are followed
sufficient information provided to
conclude that the development would not
cause harm to the amenity of the
occupiers of existing residents highway
safety or nature conservation that could
not be satisfactorily addressed at
Reserve matters stage
the development is also satisfactory in
terms of flood risk drainage
contamination ecology and Archeology
subject to detailed matters which could
be adequately addressed at Reserve at a
stage or through the imposition of
conditions
an officer's view it's a well-considered
layout including public open space and
Landscaping
the indicative framework plan shows a
north-south arrangement with substantial
new public open space and Landscaping
along the Eastern outward facing edge of
the development with a Suds feature
areas of for children's play multi-use
games area muga uh and footpaths there's
a hierarchy to propose streets in terms
of width and use of shared spaces within
the development
um
strengthening and retaining the existing
natural features of biodiversity value
new landscape edges proposed to be
multifunctional and physically would
assist integration of the scheme into
the wider landscape open space is
appropriately defined and enclosed by
buildings
Eastern edge of the development is lower
density it's about 18 dwellings per
hectare
um
and enclosed by buildings
nursery and Office hub at the Northern
end of the site help to create an active
Frontage onto steeple Road
conditional approval subject to a
section 106 are set out in the report is
recommended
and all the relevant Consultants confirm
that existing facilities and services
could meet the demands arising from the
additional growth in population that the
proposed housing would generate
subjective conditions and obligations in
the 106 that require improvements to
attendant infrastructure including for
highways and transport drainage
education and health and a Rams
contribution so the application is
recommended for conditional approval is
set out thank you chairman
thank you Mr Johnson
um we have public participation for this
application and in line with the public
participation scheme I'd now invite
those who I'm going to read out in a
moment to come up and read their
submission submissions please I'd like
to invite Mr Peter and whistle reject it
up to the
microphone first please Peter
just um I'd like to remind you you're
allocated two minutes only for public
speaking in accordance with the Public's
participation scheme and that's that
time starts as soon as you start
speaking do I need to push the button
yes that button's on red it's all right
for you now thank you very much
chairman I'm a long-standing resident of
Lexington for 23 years that this
development is even under consideration
160 plus subject objections and 320
signatures to oppose Legend and
residents are very much the voice heard
onto their voice heard because they know
the true implications of a village over
the last few years multiple local
developments have created heavy traffic
loans the Dengue area has only three
roads of exit and here lies the issue
two of these roads meet at the Village
right next to the proposal
add to these two sites being built in
lecture and as we speak and plus further
far Latina just can't cope the traffic
converging on the village now often
causes long tailbacks and adding 160
houses at that very Point clearly can't
be serious satisfactory
even now one car stops at the local shop
and we have tailbacks
drains and drains remain Bader issue the
water runs off the farms and Hill land
and goes down Richie Road and it rests
on that very proposed field you're
proposing we currently have waterlog
Gardens and heavy rain makes Burnham
Road flood and almost unpassable
Dr surges that can't cope dentists not
taking new patients and schools are
overpopulated the children having to
travel breathing in increased emissions
throwing irrelevant contractors money
will not solve the problem many years
ago we built South Woodland for us and
recently Beauty Park in Chelmsford tens
of thousands of houses built on proposed
built on Modern areas with roads and
Facilities to match surely this is the
way forward not looking up Villages that
can't cope
I believe in as we speak Sir John Witten
girl was called back plans down the road
to us in South wooden furrows simply
because the road cannot take capacity we
will just be adding to that in closing
appeal to you in regards to the local
environmental issues we hear government
schemes to introduce Wildlife trees and
areas of natural beauty back into our
lives but the proposed land is an
example of what we are trying to
preserve and farmland which is trying to
help our self-sufficiency
the country the building that is going
around election brings poor air quality
and living conditions and is bringing
stress and strengths to the residence
health and well-being modern Council
asks you to make the right decision
thank you thank you very much indeed
thank you that's perfect
the timing
okay we've got the next public speaker
which is Parish Council representative
could I please ask councilor Elaine Dean
to step up to the microphone please
good evening councilor is exactly the
same process two minutes from when you
start speaking thank you thank you
chairman I'm councilor Elaine Diane I'm
speaking on behalf of Lexington Parish
Council LPC strongly objected to this
application and we are deeply distressed
and bewildered as to how and why the
officer has found grounds to recommend
approval you only have to look at the
unprompted comments on the planning
portal to gauge that the socio-economic
benefits are not in the president's
opinion of any significant Merit
the sighting question is was not
supported by the PC and the issues and
options consultation as it's to the east
of the village
it was deemed suitable by persons that
have no knowledge of the parish or the
challenges that the residents are facing
due to the significant increasing
traffic in the past five years
we are deeply distressed as are the
residents are an expansion of the
village to the scale of 20 football
pitches is being imposed upon us without
being planned for or consulted upon
it is a significant and unwanted change
to the character and nature of the place
we choose to live we fear that if
approved by you that many will just move
away driven from their homes
there were 165 rejections on the
planning portal and a petition of 420
signatures which clearly demonstrates
residents concern
already over the plan length The Village
has seen over 150 properties added this
will take it to 310 an increase of over
60 percent without any Improvement to
services
the PC respectfully requests that
members refuse this application as it is
such a blatant departure from the local
plan its policies and the nppf
we fully recognize that this may end up
at appeal but there are clear and
reasonable material reasons for refusal
with this thought please be mindful of
the following summation
eastburg hope Parish Council versus
badberg District Council law Justice
Underhill said counselors jobs to
exercise their planning judgment and if
that leads to an expensive appeal that
cannot be helped thank you for your time
thank you very much indeed counselor
and the third public speaker please is
the applicant Ms Dawn Adams please
thank you Miss Adams is again exactly
the same process please two minutes from
when you start speaking thank you
good evening my name is Dawn Adams and I
am associate planning director for Kate
spare States who are the applicant and
we are delighted to be given the
opportunity to speak for you today I set
out in the office's report the
application seats outline planning
permission for 160 homes on land to the
east of Lexington the proposals followed
five months of pre-op discussions
including public consultation we've
sought to work openly and positively
listen to concerns and responded with
changes where possible in particular we
have included within our proposals the
allotments football pitch children's
nursery and new office space for new
businesses or work from home space
we also heard from residents who
immediately back onto the site and
amended iron scheme to include an
extended landscape buffer this means
that back-to-back distances between the
new and the proposed properties are
therefore range from 27 to 59 meters in
length which is well in excess the
policy requirements of 21 meters
Kate's people also agreed the listed
heads of terms in the committee report
and paid the council's undertaking
demonstrating our full commitment to
providing the necessary infrastructure
of this application this includes the
1.59 million towards education payments
and 115 000 towards the NHS
furthermore the application includes 40
affordable housing which is made up of a
social rent intermediate products such
as shared ownership and first homes and
as of the 18th of May 2023 there are one
that
1352 families on the Malden housing
register awaiting a new home and these
64 homes provided will directly benefit
those families
we are pleased to say that over 40 of
the site is proposed to remain
undeveloped which we feel is a sensitive
response to the site
we also want to talk a detailed
transport assessment with the
application which included traffic
surveys and included background
assessments of the traffic growth up to
2027. I hope the committee will agree
with the office's recommendation and
grab approval of this application many
thanks to your time thank you Miss Adams
thank you
members I now invite you to comment on
their broadcaster Stevens so can I just
ask for a point of clarity from the
officers which I think is important for
everything Mr Johnson can you confirm
you visited the site and can you confirm
that the officer who's dealing with this
application Mr Marsh is on the call and
available to take questions from this
from Members now
thank you Mr Johnson
uh I I haven't visited the site myself
um and neither has Mr Marsh I'm not
aware of him being on the call
um but um the off it doesn't necessarily
have to be the officer who is assessing
the application to visit the site
officers kind of visit the sites on
behalf of each other officers who have
an awareness of these sites this is a
major site
um office has been in lab services are
fully aware of the site and we've had
many discussions around this site the
nature of the village and its
relationships and that has been part of
our understanding in terms of putting
this this report together
thanks chairman
thank you very much Auntie Mr Johnson so
Council Stevens please
thank you chair
um through you chair I'd like to ask Mr
Johnson please we've got a five-year
housing land Supply we've got far more
than that at the moment
um this proposal is outside the
settlement boundary which is a material
significant departure from policy if we
were to approve this and it has merits
if we were to approve it what impact
please would that have on all other
applications that come to us before we
put in place our new ldp including other
applications on the table tonight thank
you
I must apologize kind of stuff I don't
quite understand what your question
means
what I'm saying is that we're always
hearing that decisions set precedence
so if we were to decide yes let's prove
this we're saying but a development
that's outside the settlement boundary
is okay doesn't matter that the policies
say that's not acceptable we'd be saying
yeah that's all right
and therefore I think we would be
opening the floodgates really and I'd be
interested in your comments on that
please thank you
well I'll just just be very brief
because obviously
um that that's a view for members to
take that's not what the officers are
forwarded in this application itself but
you know I set out in the report
um
and and there and there was no there is
nowhere in any national legislation that
um there is a seal into development that
development is constrained by five years
in terms of housing land Supply
um the five year housing land Supply was
introduced to ensure there was a minimum
to meet
housing need
um over any given period
um
as we probably know even the five-year
housing land Supply in itself is is
under review as to whether it is even
still relevant given that there is a
continuous unpressing need for housing
Housing Development to meet requirements
of individual areas so there is no if
I'm understanding this correctly there
is no
prejudician of any future development
there's no prejudition of the plan
there's no prejudition of the five-year
housing Supply if this development were
to be approved yeah
um
for example if it went to appeal and if
there was a a a a a refusal tonight it
went to appeal
and inspector while they would be
considering that the five-year housing
land supplies a minimum period the
Tilted balance is not engaged
they are still Bound by preeminently the
national planning policy framework to
consider the sustainability of the
development does it meet housing need
does it satisfy the other policies
within the local plan which are material
consideration and in actual fact they're
the starting point for development
considerations thank you chairman thank
you Mrs Johnson to come back Council
Stevens
please yes I would like to come back
um
so yes I know that the five year is
five-year Supply is not an um a maximum
or a minimum um sorry I know that it's
not a maximum
um but the fact remains that this would
be outside the settlement boundary our
policies say that we won't develop
outside the settlement boundary now when
we don't have a five-year housing land
Supply because of the Tilted balance
we're obliged to waive some of our
policies and look to National policy if
we get too low we can't look at any of
our policies but that's not the case
we're we're well above five in fact I
think we're above six at the moment so I
don't understand why we would waive our
policies and I think that's really my
question or my statement whichever way
you like to take it thank you thank you
well I can't really say you know any
different to what I've just said really
it's it's not a maximum I mean even when
we don't have a five-year housing Supply
it doesn't necessarily mean can't blanch
any development gets approved
um development gets refused if it
doesn't satisfy the material policies
um that guide our development plan in
terms of its General acceptability
design and all the policies that we're
familiar with within the local plan and
it works the converse
um if I mean if the development was in
the middle of nowhere it was a nice
development there were issues around
sustainability those are material
considerations we have here a
development which is adjoined to the
existing development
these were matters similarly considered
um in appeal decisions back in 2014 2015
on the south west part of the site in
terms of its proximity to the existing
settlement it's access to facilities uh
now I do appreciate it at the time
um but if I remember no not personally
remember but from what I understand we
had moved from a lack of a five-year
housing Supply at the time of the the
the the first appeal uh into a position
where we then had a five-year housing
land Supply and we're we're more robust
but the inspectors made a similar
assessment in terms of the
development credential of The Proposal
that was in front of them irrespective
of the five-year housing land position
thank you Joe thank you very much indeed
uh councilor Thompson used to speak
yeah thank you chairman um well first of
all I apologize for arriving late at
your meeting thank you and having missed
the beginning of the presentation which
is the first time in over 12 years I'm
terribly sorry for that
um but just um to clarify for anyone
who's watching I can't be taking any
further part and I shall not be voting
because I missed the beginning of the
presentation thank you thank you very
much D Council Thompson uh councilor
Passenger please
thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like to
refer to
um
2.2.2 the conclusion really and it says
there in addition
for economic benefits so no is that one
I've got my glasses let me get me
glasses
there we go I haven't taken all material
planning considerations into account it
is considered that although located
outside any settlement boundary but the
two and the Tilted balance no longer
applicable due to the council's
five-year housing Landslide position so
it says outside of the development
boundary now here we have for everyone
to see the ldp I think we can all see it
yeah there it is this was made so that
we put large sites in a plan
and this tells us where we would like to
put those large sites and we decided as
a council we would put those large
developments like this one as you can
see this is not just sort of moderate
this is a very large strategic
development
okay and we decided that large
developments would go in places such as
where we have all the facilities to
support them
okay so that's what we decided
so it says ldp doesn't say pin the tail
on the Donkey which is what we have
because what we've had is we've had the
Healer and that was a call for sites
okay so call for sites happened and
since then when we didn't have a
five-year housing land Supply one of
these sites came up none of us voted for
them it wasn't done democratically these
sites were supposed to come into Council
we were supposed to decide which sites
we wanted to develop if we had to and
then we would then make a plan the fact
is this site's coming nobody chose it so
it's coming on the hill it's been quoted
by the officer as acceptable and
sustainable and because it was mate said
so in the Healer and it's been brought
in and now it sits outside of the
settlement boundary it's not in our plan
so this is in fact unplanned and the
reason that we have a plan the reason we
make plans is because sites like this
okay they need to be supported and
that's where you get the words
sustainability and infrastructure and
these I know are open to interpretation
but when you have a site like this and
you're saying that sustainability is
based on allotments under Park well this
is in a rural area you know what one
thing people in Lexington really don't
need is allotments and Parks because
every single Village Has a Field there
is walkways we have a river walk we have
public footpaths it's not a great asset
the other thing it says Office hub this
is another great reason we have this if
you mean 100 feet or a couple of hundred
feet of office space
Office hub
what's that going to be I mean how does
that help economically it's not proven
no one's moving into an office there's
no you can't say these offices are going
to be taken up and it's going to create
Employment Office hub so that's another
you know Wonderful reason that's been
quoted why we should accept this
the other reason is a nursery a school
nursery well I can tell you A friend of
mine has a school nursery in author
which is having to close because he
can't get the staff because
unbelievably people in rural areas have
jobs we're not all sitting around
waiting for economic assets like
part-time jobs from a development which
is another reason it's been quoted why
we should accept this that it's going to
economically assist the area
these I just do not understand why we're
here discussing this
this should have never been brought to
council
thank you councilor passenger
Mr Johnson any comment uh no no no thank
you very much next name on the list is
counselor Durham please
thank you chairman chairman
looking at it from the outside and
listening to what the officer has said
you can
certainly understand why they think it's
a suitable site it abats onto an
existing settlement etc etc
but it's in latchingdon
it sits on a one of two roads and I
found myself in recent weeks going along
this particular Road
a lot more than usual they're not even
good roads they're not even a good link
on and off the Dengue
and by adding at these existing these
new houses it's just going to make the
matter worse
so you know we're also faced with
applications for other parishes other
areas on the Dengue which is just going
to compound things
and I honestly don't believe
that um
the the this is actually sustainable in
the true sense of the word because there
isn't the correct infrastructure the
objector the the resident made a very
eloquent and heartfelt objection
um highlighting the fact that there is
no um or there is no Primary Care
Facilities etc etc so I'm afraid
put this in a lot of other areas in our
district
and it would be more acceptable but
where it is
I'm afraid it certainly isn't
thank you very much little details the
time uh councilor Paula Spencer please
thank you chair so um I'm just going to
draw members attention to page 35
2.2.2 and obviously you have to remember
I do come from the murky depths of
haybridge and so um I have I have driven
along to Lexington to take a look for
myself because that's what I thought I
needed to do I do know where it is
anyway but I took another look
and I was interested in this paragraph
because it says the development would
have a degree of visual impact on the
character and setting of the town but I
didn't find any town when I went to
latching done so
I'm just a little bit surprised look for
me it's actually quite it is quite
simple this this isn't within our
policies because that table of uh you
know 106 contributions it's almost
meaningless isn't it because what are we
going to build there to bring that
forward we're not it's it's just a
nonsense that's why it's outside our
policies and I think you know I know
we've had a lot of controversy about how
fast we review the ldp and everything
else but the policies that we have in
the ldp at the moment are there for a
reason they are there for a reason and I
think we've got to think about this
because otherwise what are we going to
be doing we might as well put our
current ldp in the bin and step far to
it and then add any new one we're going
to do and put that in on top and and all
enjoy the bonfire quite frankly this
isn't going to produce what we
responsibly as a planning Authority
should want for our communities
and I think you know that's that's got
to be a consideration and and I think
it's a it it is a a planning
consideration that we should be very
mindful of thank you chair thank you
very much indeed Council Spence the
councilor Morgans next on the list
please
uh thank you Mr chairman um I I'm very
sort of taking the fact that the
um parish councils and you did and a lot
of those people that have written in and
um have pointed out the lack of
infrastructure uh in the area
um and rather puzzled that um the
officer sort of response to that is to
point them to or to appoint us members
to Clause 5.4 of the report
in particular they've pointed out the
lack of education and medical facilities
and I'm looking at 5.4 but I can't see
that that's actually answered anywhere
in that particular Clause but what I can
see if we move to page 55.
where the Essex County Council education
um have put forward their response and I
look about four lines down it says if
minded to refuse the lack of surplus
primary and secondary places library and
secondary transport in the area to
accommodate the proposed new homes
should form an additional reason for
refusal
um I think that speaks for itself thank
you very much
uh councilor fittich please
um I'd just really referring back to the
two appeals that the officer lays I mean
I think we have to bear in mind that
this these were two appeals on
relatively small plots one was ten one
was 30 houses
the office is obviously the council
originally refused the application
because it's outside the settlement
boundary
coming back on the pier with a position
of till it was viewed differently but
it's very important to note that when
the supply and inspector looked at this
site he said it's a linear extension of
the settlement boundary and he was
particularly careful to note that it
wasn't investing further deeper into the
countryside
obviously the ten were to the farther
part so that got approved when the 30
came along you basically got a gap
I mean he'd have to be rocket science to
understand that he's going to approve
that because you've now got a gap you've
just approved 10 up the road but when we
talk about policies I mean that is what
the local development plan is you've got
two primary policies that it rotates
around and that is S2 and Si in the
appeal comments the inspector noted that
Lexington wasn't the place to live you'd
have to travel every for everyday
services on a regular basis that is the
whole point of having S2 and S8 S2
directs the major development towards
those most sustainable places S8 allows
minimal development around the Villages
so you could argue if we'd have had this
policy at a time S8 would have applied
not S2 but but the problem is once we
replace 160 into S8 then it's obviously
completely out of sync with what S2 is
going to try trying to achieve and and
against one nppf paragraph 105 which is
looking to make sure that infrastructure
or development is built in the most
accessible places so whichever way we
look at it this obviously the plans are
there the plans and policies are there
of the reason all we were trying to do
is is to use the appeals in my view to
to regard Lexington sustainable well it
is
five reasonable number of houses it's
really this question of is it
sustainable for 160 the local
development plan policy say it's not the
library plans is not and things like the
nppf-105 which they're supposed to
support just getting thrown out the
window if we move forward of these types
of applications
foreign
please
thank you chair
um it might surprise you to know that
I'm actually 63. I know you can't
believe it
and and
I've lived here in the Northern District
all my life so I do know
the area well I've been going
business with the schools through there
there must come a time surely before you
do any more building do you do actually
do the infrastructure first
um
I've got haulage trucks and things and
they are now queuing around where the
old Bowling Green used to be to get
through
um latching them and and stay through
traffic in particular the school run
how those people take their children to
school on that narrow paper I don't know
but it's obviously the pollution as well
it's supporting but
as you leave Lexington towards cold
Northern two two trucks can't pass
without either diving in the Hedge I
mean it
and it's been like that for 63 years
I I can't see how another 300 cars
because that's roughly what you're going
to get they all have two car families
these days
roughly
I can't see how it's going to make it
any better but for the residents I mean
I it's it's unbearable now
so
I think the infrastructure's got to come
I know they say you build the houses
then the infrastructure comes but
it's got me a point where that comes
before the the development thank you
thank you councilor Morley councilor
Fluker please
yeah thank you very much chairman um
before I start can I just have a point
of cloud suit from the officer
um I read the comments from Essex County
Council regarding education but had they
since mitigated those objections by
agreeing uh a figure with the developer
sorry a
sorry so perhaps I didn't explain it but
I didn't quite hear it
so basically what I'm saying is the the
comments in the report regarding
education and the holding objection from
Essex County Council has that been
mitigated now by the offer of a payment
from the applicant
yes it has
well there you have it members well it's
all done on the national algorithm set
by the Tory government and the same as
the same as uh the the same as
Healthcare
um a figure comes up and then all of
those statutory responses are kicked
into touch so it's very interesting what
the uh you may laugh but it's your
party's policies and they want to build
everywhere
this planning is not political please
thank you well I think National policy
is German National policies I'd
um chairman I just take members to
paragraph
2.1.6 where it starts this application
has been made following the council's
call for sites as part of the ongoing
review
etc etc I'm sure members be interested
to hear the comments of a senior officer
of this Council who said yesterday I'm
still strongly of the view the call for
science carries such limited weight that
it has no effect on planning application
decision making is an exercise which we
have to carry out as per the national
planning policy Tim that was from the
head of policy and implementation at
this Council I've said for a long time
that we're going to get to the stage
where we have a conflict between
development management and policy and
this highlights that chairman going to
uh policies particular now I think
everybody agrees that this is outside of
the settlement boundary and if a
development is outside of the settlement
boundary then the local development
plans through policy
S8
um directs that you should go to an
urban center now that policy is very
robust and it sits there quite clearly
so you go Urban so the other thing about
this which I thought was well apart from
the fact that there's no obviously off
the case officer is not here tonight and
no one's been there I mean if anybody
knows the history of Legend and it goes
back farther than councilor Morley's 61
years
um it's it's it it's a Marshland it's a
Marshland settlement and I often come
down the steeple Road from steeple and
as you approach The Village all you see
really is the church and a few houses on
the outside so this is going to be now
as you approach The Village from stable
age you're going to see this huge
development likewise from Burnham of
Burnham road so there's an there's a
there's an issue there and there's also
something about if you then take that
away it starts to affect the intrinsic
character and and beauty of the
countryside which I also is covered by
Section 8 policy but
one thing that I do take a huge amount
of heart from and I think anybody else
who listens to this tape will and that
was what Mr
um Johnson said and he said in the
officer's view it created limited harm
uh I wrote that down that's what he said
so many in conclusion I think it should
be noted that the the
um the LPA has a five the local planning
Authority IES has a five-year housing
land site The overarching Proposal is
not within the settlement boundary
Legend and the local plan as I said
before directs that in such cases
development should be confined to urban
areas as such chairman I believe that
the Pope the proposal is not
um considered to represent sustainable
development
impacts of the development would be
significant and demonstrably outweigh
the benefit of the scheme so that would
make a contrary to policies S1 sa D1 and
H4 of our plan and also the national
planning framework
um chairman based on that I would
propose that contrary to the officer's
recommendation we refuse this
application thank you
okay
okay we just do before we go who
seconded that proposal in case where we
have a catch the white I think it counts
the white
okay fine thank you councilor stamp
please
I've seen you've been taking notes has
been going through but bear bear with me
I've got a couple of questions and a few
sticky notes and please please bear with
me
um S2 policy growth how much has
happened in Lexington so far the
um person who spoke one of the people
said 310 can we have that confirmed by
an officer I think it's really important
because bearing in mind policy sh and if
you're there with me Members I'll read
it because so councilor fitter and a few
of the members actually refer to this
and I think members that who are
watching at home maybe you don't have an
ldp on their bookcase like those other
members do it says policy S8 the
countryside and don't forget the Latin
is classed as a smaller Village in our
own ldp and it states quite clearly the
countryside will be protected for its
landscape natural resources and
ecological value as well as its
intrinsic character and Beauty outside
the Divine settlement boundaries the
garden suburbs and strategic allocations
planning permission for development will
only be granted where the intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
is not adversely impacted upon
um upon and provided it is either then
it goes into a22m chairman which council
fluka is so eloquently just um said with
his uh perspective possible reasons for
refusal but can you go to slide 20
please and I need to know slide 20 it
says where the access the Northern Road
accesses and I think it'll be beneficial
to all members and forgive me chairman
if I'm going to go over my time because
I wanted to ask this at the beginning
but counselor simply got in first as
normal but I would
I would like to see and let members see
the entrance of one of the entrances to
this road and Mr chairman if you would
bear with me at the moment I am an Essex
County counselor I don't have any
interest but I'm getting a heck of a lot
of complaints about accidents and issues
on that road so if if somebody can just
say specifically to me where the exit or
the entrance one of them would be please
do you want me to sit down because I
have got some more
no I haven't shown you
can decide because of the the you know
my methodology of cheering I I'm very
flexible with with timing obviously we
won't go forever
um but certainly when we're considering
such important applications as every
application comes here that's important
um the the two minute three minute five
minute is going to not to be strictly
applied okay so if I sit down so
everybody can see it and then can I
stand back up you certainly can thank
you very much so can I just get back to
let's get back to clarification of the
slide you said slide 20.
oh 22 right okay right that's it okay
specific information
apologies you'll have to bear with me
while I have a look through the slide
yep it's absolutely fine thank you it's
a valid question so we need to get it
clarified thank you
chairman somebody's just helped me they
said slide 11 behind the tree so
oh oh
yeah
I apologize that there's there's not
numbers on these particular slides we'd
have to change the view
in the picture
chairman it's on a Bend at a 60. so I
presume there's going to be some
mitigation that this these speed limits
if this approval is uh if this
application is approved
um to actually reduce it down that road
is absolutely getting treacherous now I
know you know my inbox is getting full
but I'll move on chairman because I'm
pushing my luck
um just to clarify this the proposal
does not include a reduction in the
speed limit that's where the highways
authorities I know it is but it would
have to how can you pull out a 60 mile
an hour on that road when you've got
that so yeah fair enough it's not a
planning reason at the moment chairman
but I think it's a really important
planning consideration if we agree to
support this as it stands to me that
should have been mitigated before it
came to this committee anyway just bear
with me so I would actually can the
officers say when the Office hub when
and how the Office hub and the
children's nurse Ray would be delivered
and chairman are based out on the facts
as being a Burnham Ward North councilor
and I'm still waiting for a nursery and
I'm still waiting for economics uh um
what's the word economic cancer Bell you
know the the um
the the economy you know when you've got
the industrial industrial units to be
delivered on in Burnham on Crouch okay
we've been waiting since the application
went in in 2014. what we end 2023 so in
the offices
um judgment when do you think that
benefit will come forward if you can
actually make it that's one question
another question the next one is
4.433 okay chairman and I'm very
interested in this the members existing
members uh page 42 existing members know
I always bang on about education and
infrastructure it says quite clearly
here that the admission to ormiston
Rivers Academy is 210 pupils per year
group I like fats we all know that
because I pulled something up at the
other meeting right that has only been
introduced for two years the 180 has
gone up to 210 and now it will continue
but it's not there yet so I think it's
really important when officers write
reports it is it is factual yeah the the
existing School numbers are 180 except
for the first two years so that's
actually not accurate so if you bear
with me
um and I actually want to know this
there's a residential travel information
pack of sustainable transport what does
that consist of because the David Wilson
homes opposite me a resident colored me
at the Dengue 100 bus Group because I do
go to lots of things and said we've
never had a residential uh information
pack Travel which I know this Council
approved when that house site was
approved so what does that consist of
and will it be delivered or is it just
another something cut written down and
the last thing I think if you'll be
pleased to know chairman it says I'm
4.9.3 and I am concerned about this it
categorically says that the water
recycling center
um anglian water does not have the
capacity now many years ago cancer
flucaly can remember this and cancer
crack because it was a cancer at the
time welcome back but he he we we know
that the southmidster application was
refused on those grounds we know the law
has changed now and the water company
has to accommodate it but my inbox is
full of latches residents complaining to
me about flooding and its flooding which
will back onto this development so I do
think we need to be cautious about that
and I lied I've got one more by the
looks of it I'm so sorry and it says 5.4
page 49 the main benefits of The
Proposal are considered to be as follows
social benefits for providing Market
homes in a variety of sizes and I've put
totally agree with this as long as it's
in the right place and as far as I'm
concerned this development is not in the
right place and there's lots of
questions there so I'd appreciate the
answers thank you thank you Council stem
yeah there's lots of questions Mr
Johnson thank you well I'm afraid I
wasn't able to capture them all because
I was scouring through my documents so
maybe because just in terms of the
questions if you could just just
questions yeah because the Stampy and
I'll attempt to address them chairman
well let's start with the delivery three
of the nursery and and the The Hub when
do you envisage in this invest that
being delivered if at all it will
because I use the example of Burr West
opposite me was approved in 2014 or
replied in 2014. it still hasn't
materialized the industrial area the the
nursery school which we know we haven't
got any places in Burnham German I still
hasn't been delivered so how is this
going to be delivered thank you
um well you may not like the answer I'm
going to give but it's actually one of
the easier questions to answer in the
sense that this is an outline
application
um the only matters for consideration
here is is access so so I I cannot and
and in fact actually at no point can I
actually tell you when these will be
delivered because it would depend upon
how applications will be uh determined
if this application was approved so
there is so that there is a period in
within which Reserve matters
applications have have to be submitted
to the local planning Authority I mean
that in itself runs to a number of years
so it's an indeterminate period then
there's a whole bill scale so that's not
an answer that I can give you it's not
going to ask for the local planning
Authority itself can you thank you
chairman I come back with that because
we get told so many times when the
previous gentleman Mr Lee was the charge
and I think a lot of
exist the older members I don't mean old
as in older members would appreciate
that we have been told so many times
that if we don't raise it now when it
comes to the reserve matters it is not
included so I think it is really
important that somehow Mr Johnson you
wasn't here but I can re I can recollect
all the time Matt Lee saying it to us
that you can't raise it now it should
have been raised at the at the outline
stage so I do think it's important no
it's it's sorry I don't want us to be
too much in a a kind of call and review
type type
time time situation but um
yes it's it's it is important to debate
but in terms of how the application is
managed in itself in itself follows a
format
and that's not a format that although
the matter is raised or not I mean the
matter is raised in the sense that it's
a consideration under the headings of
the section 106 in this application for
it to be taken into account so it's
raised in that sense so there's not
necessarily the need to actually debate
that as such in terms of what the
application will deliver that's actually
there in terms of what's on offer but in
terms of on-site delivery that's a
completely different matter that's not
something that the local Authority can
even put into report in in that
particular sense outside of the time
scales within which an application would
have to remain valid for these matters
to be submitted for consideration thank
you chairman thank you very much indeed
and I'll shut up now because I haven't
had the things answered it's just shut
up you always so um I haven't had the
answers that I really think was is
important for members to make an
informed um decision on this application
yeah I think um there was a lot of
questions in there and I think and just
just allow me to speak there's a there
were a lot of questions in there and I
can concur that we were as members of to
raise them at this point so there's
validity in raising those questions at
this point
um councilor White please
thank you Mr chairman now for some
reason this iPad has decided it's not
going to load the ldp which I have in
iBooks but um the first thing that is
fine the first policy is D1 3.2 now this
part of
um Malden is well renowned for its open
context and Big Sky and that formed part
of the ldp and the assessments for the
local character and I haven't seen that
actually mentioned and where this
development is situated I supported the
infill houses between opposite the jack
center
um on that area there which this butts
onto I supported that it's in a fairly
useful area I didn't mind it you know it
didn't feel it's fine this isn't and
this this ribbon that goes up to the
north is completely incongruous and for
me this is the introduction of
incongruous housing into a rural rural
area which is open context Big Sky flat
Landscapes um so it doesn't meet 3.5
which is a local character it doesn't
meet 3.10 which makes the fish use or
reuse of land under Section S8 on the
settlement boundaries again we've got
the open context flat landscape in the
dingy area and again it's the Congress
introduction of houses in the area H4
effective use of land what is the land
designation
um is it is it class one or is it class
two it won't be class three and have we
done an assessment of the actual
viability of that for farming land
because I suspect it's class one
um because the Essex Clay is
um very fertile and very good for um
farming so really should this be built
on for that one
um on 4.17 harms the character Lexington
is designated a smaller Village
and it says in the report on 4.1.7 the
beauty is not impacted well again if you
drive on that road from Mainland to
Lexington that absolutely impacted that
you can see as far as London Malden if
you look to the left you can see up to
all Thorne and you can see a long long
way so that's absolute answer completely
discrew the 4.1.7 I have a question
um in your report you mentioned um the
green networks the north of the site
onto the main road really
um but that's that's a bit hit and miss
that's the first question
um as Council stamp raised
4.4.4.2 and 4.4.4.3 on page 42.
we've got wait times
um and I know that both practices in
Mayland wooden which are mentioned are
have long Waits you also can't walk to
them for this site and being the
well-being chair you should be able to
walk to medical facilities
um which you cannot do from that area
there
um so that that's another thing and the
other thing is they can put as much
money they want to it my nephews just
qualified as a GP and I can assure you
there's a massive source of GP so you
can throw whatever money you like at it
you're not going to find doctors this
should be in the report it's not
mentioned and 4.5.8 paragraphs four and
five again the open rural views um and
Flatland
I've got a question on 4.1 3.6 air
quality does not mention the standing
traffic on the road and this morning I
was driving to work and there was a
delay there was a lorry of bricks parked
in the main Road in Lexington which
isn't supposed to be there it's supposed
to go into the development size and
Legend and perhaps we can have a look at
the parking plan and I queued from the
road to lawling um farm lawling house
and I queued from there for half an hour
all the way to Lexington that was one
Lorry and what this doesn't mention is
the impact of the air quality with the
standing traffic outside the primary
school that's not mentioned and it's not
mentioned in the conditions so that's
another question on 4.1 3.17 a lighting
again doesn't really mention that and
this should have been assessed prior to
the application being determined policy
D5 flooding on one of your slides I
can't remember which one
um there's actually areas that are
subject to standing surface water now
that water I can tell you was driving
this road every day he goes into the
ditches and that runs across the road
from Lexington to uh well the other side
of Lexington
um the other thing is it's not going to
increase flooding um but I say it goes
into the ditches um so where are any
tests for flooding carried out I
couldn't see those in the report
um uh in one
um again that's a question I've already
mentioned it policy the green instructor
Network to the north
um the other other question I have is on
the axis
um off of the election road on the
Northern side if correct me if I'm wrong
but I understand that that's next to the
electrical substation that's not
mentioned in the report
um so following on from all those my
reasons for refusal should members be
um decided up policy S1 tilted balance
does not apply as we have a 6.35 year
housing land Supply policy S8
introduction of incongruous housing into
a rural area which is flattened is
renowned for the Big Sky as an open
rural views sustaining to be
sustainability does not meet the third
term for sustainability the impact on
the open Countryside which is severe
um it also does not have doctors for the
city which can which can only be reached
by car and again that does not meet the
sustainability test policy D5 for the
flooding in the report it shows areas
Associate's standing surface water
um and on page 56 does not mention the
flooded areas
um it also does not mention if you look
on page 56 anglian water mentioned that
it's only 15 meters from the pumping
station and that is going to have an
adverse impact on the houses that are
within that area so my question is how
many houses are in that area also that
pumping station along with all of all
sort runs along tiny pipes into maylands
and Mainland can't cope and I know that
because they have to constantly get
access to use lorries to pump out the
pumping station
um so again page 56 mentions the smell
downwind uh policy I2 Health and
well-being and access to Services you
cannot walk to mail and there are no
paths
um so that's it really thank you so that
I can shorten the questions if you need
them but if I go up it's access near to
electricity substation policy N1 green
infrastructure Network to the north
where's it going I can't see anywhere
you can put it
um and there's another one here
somewhere the the
um ldp and the uh views of the open
Skies in the district of the Lindsey 100
thank you
hey guess what Mr Johnson
again I'd have to just say that my
answer can only be quite short and and
it's and it it it it it doesn't mean I'm
not having regard to the comments you'll
make this is a this is an outline
application uh yes this is an outline
application the only matters for
consideration are access the
the information to support
this application which is not just all
and cannot all be contained within the
officer's report
is also within all the substantial
material which is on on the website so
to be informed about why the context of
what's summarizing the report would need
to also have reference to the various
studies which are in the application on
the website the consultations uh invite
uh anyone interested in this application
to look at all the material facts so a
number of the points raise and I do
appreciate these as a number of points
but these are not for consideration in
its application there are
37 conditions
um the report hopefully is you know
helpfully sets out the amount of their
various categories and we can look at
what is required to be submitted under
any reserve matters application if this
application were to be supported so much
of the detail which
it may be the view that it might be
taken as being material to determine
this application may actually fall given
that the nature of this particular
application just as a particular point I
wanted to make thank you chairman thank
you very much indeed Council Neil please
I want to give every Council the
opportunity to speak Council Durham
thank you thank you chair unfortunately
on my hand wasn't quick enough and uh
councilor stamp and councilor white have
used most of the reasons why I wanted to
speak but my biggest concern as a as a
you know user of this road is the access
on the Northern side
the access is within the 60 mile an hour
limit
um into into the village and as many
councilors know and have said
traveling through Lexington at any point
during the day is is can be a nightmare
if someone wants to buy something from
the from the shop
um this this access to a fast throwing
road that nobody's going to be able to
pull out of that and turn right and
continue off towards male and sea and
out into the dingy
if people know the area near North
fanbridge access to North vanbridge I
can foresee that this access will be as
dangerous as the north fanbridge access
is currently so I have big concerns
about access to the site from this side
and I can foresee that this will then
Force any traffic that is on that site
to come out onto the Burnham site
because it may be easier for them to get
out of that site from here
but I agree with
accounts of the stamp and councilor
White's comments as well thank you thank
you very much
Mr Johnson yeah thank you sir just to
make a comment on the highways issues
because obviously that's been raised by
a number of council councilors
um
and obviously a number of you have heard
me say these sort of things before I
will draw attention to the highway
comments
within the offices report under 7.2
um
and I'll just read a little bit of it
Highway Authority has visited the site
and assessed the submitted information
supplied by the applicant and has
concluded that in Highway terms it's not
contrary to national and local Highway
and transportation policy and current
safety criteria then they're going to
talk about the transport assessment has
analyzed the impact of the traffic
generation to the satisfaction of the
highway Authority and it's not
considered to have a significant not to
say that there isn't any but a
significant
and again just on that point you know
our assessments are not are not in terms
of absolutes here that there will be
impact or there will be no impact there
may be some impact but it's how much
impact this is this is in terms of
whether it's visual impact or in terms
of Highway impact or any of the other
constraints and issues out that that we
raise as part of these reports so
yeah
if members are minded to refuse it we
just have to be mindful that
particularly where we're
recommended reasons for refusal contrary
to statutory consultancy responses they
would have to be significant and robust
responses to this
and I know some don't like saying this
but we do have to consider that these
are things that
um could be putting us into cost domain
uh domains if we can't robustly
challenge these in terms of your own
Highway assessments to counter some of
these the assessments that's been part
of this report and considered
satisfactory by highways thank you
chairman thank you very much Mr Johnson
cancel the bill please
thank you Mr chairman I'll try and keep
it brief because members have covered
most of the points where I was a little
bit late well cut it a bit fine this
evening guess why
I had to come through latching and
someone wanted some shopping
um I'm I struggle we some time ago we as
a council declared a climate emergency
and yet we keep on building on
floodplain
where we live is essentially flood plain
edged by very valuable salt marsh
members we have several sites of special
scientific interests
we are going to sink literally if we
just keep building where where does the
water go cancel the Y has mentioned the
um where the water goes in Lexington
we can't keep doing this and it makes a
mockery of our other climate policies
but um I spoke to David Lincoln you'll
have missed it on the slides but so one
of them you might have noticed that
there's Kennels
very successful very important local
business
two Fields away from this proposed
development site now the candle owners
would have liked to have come spoken
tonight but they they didn't apply in
time
they had to they had to put in they they
recently within the last few years they
expanded and they had to put in
significant and very costly sound
mitigation
for the to mitigate the noise for the
existing development
move two Fields closer
what's gonna happen
now the kettle owners not some he's not
interestingly asking us to refuse the
application but what he's asking is
whether we're prepared to um face
costs where residents of the new
development might sue us or what
mitigations we will condition the
development in order to make sure that
residents of the new development aren't
bothered by the noise of barking dogs
from the Kennels
thank you thank you councilor Bill any
comments
I can't have any specific comments as
such in that respect I mean obviously
this is an outline application where
there are medical details in terms of
the housing to be constructed how
they're constructed the details of our
orientations
where they are in proximity to
um
you know noise
um disturbance the illustrative master
plan that we showed above is just
illustrative in that in that sense where
it comes down to detail consideration of
of of of the peculiarities of the site
where maybe the sensitive receptors Etc
that sort of thing from barking dog Etc
these are things that we've taken into
consideration this is where our
environmental health officers would
consider the localized impact in terms
of noise does a development address that
in terms of its orientation it's build
Windows all these sorts of things yeah
so these are matters again for any
reserve matters application if this
application would be to approved in one
way or the other it's not something that
we can consider now and we cannot make
definitives in terms of the illustrative
master plan while it gives us an idea we
can't make determinations in terms of
detail on an illustrative plan thank you
Jim thank you very much indeed Mr
Johnson
point of interest on that actually
because
okay so as far as I understand it we've
got a kennel we've got a kennel close by
which we know produces enough noise for
our own environmental health Team to
implement certain conditions to stop
that noise going to houses which are
further away now it seems to me that if
this development was permitted then the
responsibility of protecting the the
residents of this development would fall
on the kennel that can't be right and
and if it was an industrial unit next
door which was open six and a half day
five and a half days a week eight to ten
we would be saying no because we've had
this at Red Lion's farm so I I
appreciate this is only Reserve matters
and I can see you chomping at the bit to
come back so I'll I'll give way but it
it is an interesting one thank you
right now obviously have Reserve matters
where we consider issues like this it
would be for the developer to
demonstrate that the any future
occupiers will be protected in terms of
their immunity if that cannot be
demonstrated you know there's no
obligation
to be improved just because there's an
outline application so these are matters
that we would consider at that stage
thank you chairman thank you very much
indeed uh finally councilor fittich
please
so you check
obviously this application has been
approved in principle because the social
economic benefits I I
did a study really to try to understand
how planning specs has attributed weight
to the to the components of the
application so we've got building we've
got green space and we've got
affordability now consistently when I
was looking at the um responses from
inspectors and I used two in the
district that are both um were dismissed
on appeal that were large developments
one in great Tottenham one in total van
tonight both one was 80 one was 97.
um tilt was applied outside the
settlement boundary all the normal stuff
that we're seeing today but they would
regard the actual benefits of
construction as relatively low because
it's short-lived I mean it range from
low to significant
um the the Green Space because the
Green's placing his space consistently
that would just detects that was
consistently viewed as being of not
significant value or low value or low if
you like benefit because it wouldn't be
used by all of the community all the
time it's really more for the the actual
uh developer itself an affordability
interestingly enough in the um in I
think it's a tall Zone the the actual
modern officer regarded as a relatively
low benefit
in the scheme of the the amount we've
got to build so we've obviously got
quite big differences here in how the
officers in this assessment have viewed
the weight of these benefits because
the inspector summed up
um the toll sounds like we're saying and
such conflict with policy is that's a
very weighty matter
which their derives are considerability
of harm in an overall planning balance
the adverse effects of granted planning
Mission would significant demonstrate
outweigh the benefits when it's just
against the framework so for this the
officer to see such economic benefit or
on Social Security I don't understand
how it's been balanced so I was hoping
that explained how they've waited these
things so it basically overweights all
of the harm that's being done from
Department of developed like it just
doesn't seem to me to be in sync at the
moment
Mr Johnson
um well I mean I mean in that all I can
do is I mean you know different
audiences different readers different
assessors will give the weight that they
feel is appropriate weight May sometimes
be subjective wait maybe you're
calculative it just really depends but I
I just want to just pick up on the point
um that you made counselor politic about
almost as though there's a a deemed
approval in principle for this
development site because of the Healer
because that's not correct
the report they're set out and this has
been discussed many a Time the Healer
does not give any form of approval for
any development it is part of the core
for science process within which
um through legislation I know many of
you know this already so I'm not saying
anything that's new
um
developers interested in participals
submit uh their their sites because they
want it obviously to be finally adapted
within the local plan when they missed
as a presumption in favor of development
yeah
now through that process and again I've
said this before you may get a hundred
sites submitted yep that site then it
goes through an iterative process in
terms of its suitability it's scoring
um I mean I'm sure in our current local
plan you know it went through the same
process I've been through the local plan
process in other authorities uh
particularly when you're at the local
plan public inquiry where these things
are exercised yeah and then the you know
the the notion of 100 is reduced then to
you know the five six or ten sites that
may be considered suitable for the local
plan so a number of them get
um thrown out the majority of them now
if a developer on the base of the fact
that
um the
um the the assessment on the court for
science may say there's a potential for
Resident development residential
development many size of a potential for
residential development doesn't mean
they're suitable right it could be for a
number of factors but there is a
potentiality if a developer submits a
proposal on that basis then that's a
risk that they are taking that's not
because they've been encouraged there's
no deemed approval they can't be
redeemed approval they cannot even be a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development it's not within a local plan
so that actually falls away in terms of
what we think the Healer may do
um and I sort of gather that because we
go through this price process and we may
comment that there is a potential we're
actually saying it's acceptable that's
clearly not the case and that's even set
out within this report thank you
chairman thank you Mr Johnson thank you
for the point of clarity uh councilor
Hayward
sorry I'm just going through the um road
safety audit response report on here
just something to going back to the the
roads themselves and that corner of
steeple road we were talking about we're
on the summer is in there actually says
Vehicles turning will lead to shunt side
swipe type collisions at this new
Southern access Junction the audit team
examined the speed data provided there's
a concern that Vehicles will be
accelerated as they exit The Village
into the national speed limit part of
steeple Road this will increase the risk
of conflict between Vehicles turning
right into the new Northern access
Junction
Vehicles accelerating whilst approaching
stationary Vehicles would increase the
risk of shunt side swipe type collisions
so I just want to put that in as my part
towards that that Junction is a very
dangerous Junction thank you councilor
Heywood
members I think we've had quite a robust
and open debate thank you for everybody
who's spoken this evening
um we have had a seconded proposal
because the recommendation for the
officers of the person hasn't been put
out or seconded but we do have live
Council fluka put a proposal for refusal
um bounced by councilor White
um so that then becomes the motion which
we must vote upon first and if that
fails then we go back to the original
motion
um so Tara did you capture the the
recommendations or the reasons for
refusal
well we need to we need to know just
wait a second with Tara comes on oops so
thank you Mr the ones and with respect
it was my proposal my emotion thank you
Council and wives thank you very much
I'm sure that um if you ask Miss bird
I'm sure by now she will have grasped it
then take a seat just for a moment
cancel the one please and Miss bird can
you confirm you can hear
you thank you very much can you confirm
there's councilor fluka's recommendation
for refusal please
second by
e okay thank you so councilor fluka can
you give your reasons for refusal please
thank you chairman um
that the proposal is not it's not
considered represent sustainable
development and the adverse impacts of
the development development would be
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits of the steam scheme
contrary to policies S1 S8 D1 and H4 of
the modern District local development
plan 2017 and the national policy
planning framework
yeah
I I I I did listen to what councilor
white said but I I concur Mr Johnson in
in in in so far as the fact that we're
not quite dealing with that at this
stage thank you thank you is there any
comments Mr Johnson before I put it to
the boat
um
just in terms of the clarity on the on
the not sustainable development I mean
that's just in terms of and obviously
you talk about the benefits to do not
outweigh the harm so obviously there's
that link there that's absolutely right
I mean I'm happy members to add S2
because I think that was mentioned so
perhaps somebody can just remind me
policy S2 safe getting the book out
deals with
oh right okay I'd apologize I thought
that was in essay so I clearly mentioned
that that you know we should we should
if if something's not within a
settlement boundary then it should be
directed towards an urban area and I I
think it's absolutely important that we
we sort of make this clear because I'm
I'm sure that the tape from this meeting
will be listened to by others at another
time thank you chairman thank you
Council okay just for clarity so it's
not sustainable development because it's
not located within the urban area
yeah that's cool okay okay members is
everybody clear on what we're voting for
okay do members want to take this by a
cent or does anybody call for a recorded
vote
the show of hands their members has been
cited so those in favor of refusal based
on the recommendations please show
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
23. I just got to check it again members
because it's very important I get a ride
for the clerk yeah cancel the prep one
two three four five six seven eight nine
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
23 years 24 that's 24 for refusal any
against
any abstentions
members that recommendation for refusal
has passed we now move on
members I just um
you can hear it in my voice I've just
got to adjourn for one moment while I
just go and get a glass of water
to so I can speak for the rest of the
meeting uh yeah thank you I won't start
till Council the Pratt comes back
because then we can uh we won't be able
to vote on the issue in hand
I'm adjourning Tara for uh it's 8 58
until eight until nine pm
thank you
thank you Lord Kevin
thank you Miss bird members thank you
for your patience we now recommence the
meeting at 902 PM we move on to agenda
item six which is reference
2201-256
resm this is land south of Wick Hill and
linebrook way Western in Malden Essex
I'll just point to members there was a
member update in relation to this item
of business distributed earlier the
officer presenting this application is
Miss Matthews thank you Miss Matthews
would you please present the report
consultation responsive now received
from the council strategy team and it is
on the members update and the extra
condition that's recommended there as a
result of her comments and I also was
going to highlight the request
from the um well the um I've also
received a query from the applicant
about condition number four querying the
need for electric vehicle charging
charging points for the visitor spaces
and as a result of that um if members um
agree the recommendation I would
um advise that condition four needs to
be amended to emit reference to visitor
parking spaces charge electric vehicle
charging points
so this is an application Reserve
matters application for the approval of
appearance Landscaping layer to scale of
phase three the Western parcel
um of the um part of the South Morgan
South Morgan Garden suburb and comprises
of 78 dwellings new public open space
and car parking and who's following
following the approval of outline plan
planning permission for up to over a
thousand dwellings and employment area
local Center education
Etc as part of the wider South Northern
Garden suburb they're strategic the site
um is subject to a strategic master plan
framework and design codes as part of
the garden suburb
um as referred to in the agenda
so this is the location plan for the
site and it includes the approved
phasing one and two to the Northeast and
Southeast
um as well as the approved employment
area to the north west phases one and
two have got detailed Reserve matters
approval are under construction and the
approved means of access to the site is
from Mortal Murrow to the north
a green waveforms a northern section of
the site along the linebook corridor
Beyond which is the employment land as I
referred to own this now
um and another Greenway is located along
but beyond the southern site boundary
the infrastructure for this phase and
The Wider Western parcel has already
been approved
um back in 2019 application
this is the proposed layout for the um
the site it's got a spine Road it's
divided site Southwest to North East and
the resident development is divided into
a series of blocks separated by a
hierarchy of internal roads
this plan shows the story Heights so the
blue is two-story and the brown or
grayish is the single story so there's a
number of single Bungalows
um and two-story houses
this this um plan shows the location the
affordable housing element of The
Proposal which is a mixture of single
story Bungalows and apartments and which
is in accordance with the mix set out in
the um the section 106 associated with
the outline planning permission
these are examples of Street Scenes
um and it's considered that the
appearance character appear with the
dwelling proposed would be appropriate
to this Garden suburb and consistent in
relation to the schemes approved to the
previous phases within both the eastern
and western parcels
this plan obviously you won't be able to
read all the writing but just gives an
idea of the Landscaping master plan for
for the site
Landscaping being one of the
Reserve matters for approval
this plan gives an idea of the
ecological improvements that are
proposed which includes bat boxes and
Nest bird boxes and Hedgehog Highway
and this is a connectivity plan showing
how the site or occupy the site will be
able to connect with the rest of the
garden suburb and Beyond so the
application site is here in in phase
three so there'll be a mixture of
options of walking cycling and there's a
bus route that will run through the site
and obviously this is the vehicle access
as well
at least some examples of house types so
these are the the Bungalows that are
proposed
and one bed and two bed bungalows
and then we've got um the one bed
apartment that's the um
most of those will be affordable
and two-bed apartments again affordable
unit
and then these are some examples of the
market housing
very similar to those that have already
been approved on the previous phases
and then these are some photos of the
site
um at the moment it's um part that's
like a service so and Builders yard a
construction camp for for The Wider
development
um and then there's the bottom photo is
the site access
um one of the main site actors into the
site from Malden Road and then there's
some examples of the phases that I've
already been being completed
um perhaps it's worth pointing out that
this um is the final phase of the
development that was granted permission
originally as part of the outline
planning permission and which granted
permission for up to a thousand houses
so there's 78 houses will will take it
up to the Thousand maximum limit that
was imposed as part of that Airline
Commission
but the principle the development um has
been accepted as site forms part of a
large area of land which benefits from
outline plan permission
most recently granted in 2022 the
variation and a part of which means of
access to the site was approved the
provision of the dwellings proposals
will make a positive positive and
significant contribution to meeting the
housing needs of the district including
affordable housing current application
is for this as just said for the Final
Phase of development
and does not include all the land
covered by the existing outline plan
permission but having assessed the
details submitted in relation to layout
scale appearance and Landscaping in the
context of the master plan famous and
design codes and the outline plan
permission
and it's considered development would be
acceptable in terms of its character and
appearance and the quality of life that
it occupiers of the post dwellings also
considered that development will be
acceptable in terms of Highways access
parking flood risk and nature
conservation appropriate links with the
existing urban area of Malden and the
educational recreational and Community
facilities to be provided within the
garden suburb would be provided the
details of the recreational facilities
propose will be satisfactory
based on the Verve it's recommended that
the application is approved thank you
thank you Miss Matthews um public
speaking we have a public participant
for this plan application
um I'd now just like to invite the agent
Mr Joseph Daniels please
foreign
as you know you have two minutes uh from
the moment you start speaking please
thank you thank you good evening chair
members my name is Joseph Daniels I'm a
planning consultant at Savills
representing Crest Nicholson Easton who
are the applicant
the applicant is naturally pleased that
the application is recommended for
approval since it represents the
culmination of a significant amount of
work and positive engagement with the
council officers including a series of
pre-application meetings
the application follows the outline
permission granted in 2016 on this
allocated site in the local plan which
gave consent for up to a thousand
dwellings an employment area local
Center primary school early years Child
Care Facilities open space allotments
playing fields and other Associated
infrastructure
phase three of the western parcel will
deliver 78 high quality new dwellings in
a range of different sizes set within
large areas of landscape public open
space
the application also includes 30
affordable housing ensuring that 30
overall will be provided across all
three phases uniquely as this is the
Final Phase it will deliver the 24
elderly affordable dwellings in the form
of flats and Bungalows which are
required under the terms of the outline
permission
the scheme Accords with the design codes
and the master plan the design fulfills
the policy aim of delivering an
attractive new community with high
quality housing including policy
compliant provision of affordable homes
and family homes which will both
contribute towards the Castle's housing
targets
if I could also just come back on the
officers Point regarding condition 4 to
clarify the applicant's request it is
simply that the council imposes the same
condition wording that was used at the
previous phase two stage of the scheme
which would enable the council to assess
the details that are submitted against
the SBD requirements when they are
submitted that's all
thank you for your time thank you Mr
Daniels
thank you
okay members uh open the chamber for
comment
councilor White
thank you Mr my concern really is uh one
I object this application because the
flooding and it looks like there's an
hinduation Pond to the north of the
Bungalows so was this in the flood zone
area two and three I think it might have
been for this the west but I just wanted
to clarify next single story houses
and the other thing is there doesn't
seem to be sufficient parking
and foot ways in the middle of the
development I can't I can't quite work
out how you're going to park in front of
the houses that are towards the center
that second row of Bungalows
um it's which used to be bigger I just
can't quite see where they're going to
park
um you've got the gardens in between
um and I'm finding out on all sides of
the development where are people going
to park and what how do they pass each
other
um and has the bin lures get in there
and turn around just it's very strange
it's a very peculiar development
um
the the the access to the house it just
doesn't make sense
thank you
um the um the development is not in
flood zone two or three
um and the drainage and um food race
ailments have have been dealt with as
part of the partly the outline
permission but also the infrastructure
planning permission that I referred to
in my presentation
um so in terms of the amount of storage
they need and the drains and everything
that that has been um all um dealt with
and approved pre already
um in terms of access and parking and
this is the the main spine Road through
through the whole um
inspiring through the whole of the the
parcel but it does actually go through
the middle of this site excuse me
um so there's a road that goes down here
and you turn around here and accessing
here and you
um Private Drive Arrangement um along
here so there's parking in here for
these
parking here for those and parking here
for that
um
yeah and then there's some parking on
the road here and then there's a
communal area of parking
um here for for the flats
does that answer your question
comes back
um I still can't see how these houses
how there are enough parking spaces
because they're only in one bedroom
Bungalows because one or two cars
but the spaces
big enough and presumably if they're one
two bedroom Bungalows there'll be
elderly residents they'll need to be
very near to their cars
um and for me the design is poor is that
it doesn't the parking does not suit the
development because we need to be
mindful that we're an ancient population
and I know that we did some developments
in Maitland many many years ago that
just do not have enough but they're
Dreadful they don't have enough parking
and this to me looks like it could
become one of those and so I am
concerned about silence I know the um
the actual
um permission is there because it's one
of our strategic sites but that doesn't
mean to say that we shouldn't have a
good design and I I don't see why we
don't have a parking space in front of
each and every bungalow
this doesn't make sense and and you know
how big are they
maybe this this obviously it's um
not that clear because of the scale of
the drawing trying to get it down onto a
um an overhead but the and there there
are enough parking spaces to comply with
the adoptive standard and the spaces are
the right size
um one bedroom loans would only need one
parking space
um two bedrooms and above two or two and
three would need two parking spaces so
there there are enough
um these can't really sit very well but
they're the parking spaces there in
front of those Bungalows
um as well as around the back and
um
yeah I mean I'd have to blow the drawing
up for you to be able to read read what
the the figures say but that is
something that has been assessed and
checked because that is obviously quite
an important factor
uh yeah thank you I would just add to
that that um in the report
5.6.2
[Music]
through to
6.4 sets out all the parking standards
the parking base sizes
um the total number the percentage of
vehicle uh visitor parking spaces
um so totally in compliance in that
respect but I do take um Miss Matthew's
point it may be just visually how it may
appear in terms of um the the image on
the screen thank you chairman yeah thank
you Mr chairman for let me come back oh
yeah my thing is the design is not
conducive to the occupants who like you
to live in the one and two bedroom house
it's like a big concern of design design
is a major reason uh for approval or
refusal the other thing is
um every single application
um where is it either way
um
the um the same answer
um the um the outline plan permission
does provide for a bridal way
um to go along the edge of the site the
conditions on the outline permission
require details of that
um where a proposal
um
where the reserve matters is adjacent to
that boundary of the site which
obviously this one is not and the um
this this issue did come up as part of
discussions in advance of the committee
and
um I've been told that the applicant
um
the details will be coming forward
shortly under a separate Reserve matters
application
um and as I've just said the wording and
the credit condition and requires
details to be submitted for the
development which involves the relevant
land which is the current which the
current Reserve matters does not
trigger
thank you is that can we do just a
question for clarity can we do because I
thought all Reserve matters were done at
that time unless there's a specific
exclusion
so all the reserve matters should be
done at that point unless there's some
some items specifically held back so
you're saying there's things that are
specifically held back here
but the the
um
the uh the process and outline
permission for a bigger scheme like this
and then the reserve matters come in and
yeah I understand that you know at
different times
um so they don't all come in together as
as we've had
um in this case this is now phase three
and and on these and Parcels at least
two phases yeah two phases
um so they come in gradually but that is
um
uh and and to say that the outline
permission does
um cover the requirement for a by the
way but the wording of condition
um means that that condition doesn't
apply and to this application of this is
in the middle of the site and not not
meant for them I understand that I know
the site very well thank you very much
any Council fluka please join our
giveaway to counselor Stan councilor
stamp thank you thank you chairman
mine's a quick question it's only just
come up because it's happened on some of
my sites um opposite where I live and
that's a covenant that white Vans are
not allowed to park on their drives
thumbs
yeah commercial any commercial vehicle
is not allowed is this what cancer
Thompson you shaking your head can I
help
oh okay
um so can you tell me is that
restrictive on here because it's
actually now creating substantial
problems where they're actually parking
on the streets and we're actually
starting to have not neighbor walls but
certainly disagreements and letters that
are going out to Residents because
they're not allowed to pack their
commercial vehicle out on their Drive
outside their property they have to park
it on the highways which then comes into
question what counselor white is
actually raising about parking spaces
and are they adequate and I'm sure the
developer is not allowed to speak but
it's worth taking forward that this is
actually happening now well it is in
Burnham thank you any comments
um
yeah through Sherman there'd be no uh
restriction or limitation to the
planning process that stop people if
it's their own work vehicle parking
their van on their driveway overnight
um in the same ways that that I might
pop my car on my driveway overnight
um but that sounds that is a covenant
which would be the developer
um or you know putting that Covenant on
when they sell the plot
um rather than anything to do with the
council or the planning permission so
chairman thank you Miss Matthews but the
reason I'm raising it is it's happening
it's actually happening when these these
developments have been built so it's
actually having an effect on people who
are living on these new Estates that
we're
um accept uh providing Fortune
comment Miss Matthews
no again
Mr Johnson
I'm just thinking about you know how
reasonable it would even be for us to
even consider that I mean given the
different sizes of Vans our parking
standards which we can robustly apply
through the planning process or you in
any appeal process is based on finite
standards I mean
I mean if it's a large van I mean how
big is a parking space and the impact on
that in terms of the overall parking
provision within the street or the
highway I'm just trying to think about
the the reasonability of even trying to
apply that but covenants are not
exercised through the planning process
which is what seems to be the case here
in terms of what's Happening well in
your areas and and I do have
appreciation because obviously some of
those have come through the enforcement
process so I'm aware of that yeah so
thank you as a as an elected member it's
our duty to raise the issues that are
coming forward from developments that we
have actually approved so I understand
it's a covenant because we've actually
looked into it and we've done a lot of
research for people in Burnham um but
what I'm saying is if there is something
we can do and I actually don't think it
is unreasonable I think when you have
your pre-apps with the developers it's
something you could possibly mention
that these issues are coming forward now
Council Thompson you're shaking your
head again if you'd like to say
something please do
thank you councilor Fluker yeah thanks
Tom and I I think that Mr Johnson
answered the question very well when he
directed um councilor white to where it
speaks to parking standards and I think
it's I think it's important for all
members to look at some new
supplementary planning documents there's
quite a few of them they support the ldp
and they often get forgotten so I think
that's important
um and and of course there's that thing
that Mr culture always says if you
haven't read the report you shouldn't
vote
um and that document itself also covers
electric charging points which now have
to be in all new properties although I
don't believe anybody's been able to
address what happens in the parking
courts so where you've got blocks of
Apartments how do you deal with that so
be interesting to see that but on this
business about restrictive governments
and parking trade vehicles
um I think we should be mindful of this
because we have a situation in South
Minster where this is now happening and
we're ending up with with sort of Van
Transit science Vans being parked in
side streets of the development because
the developers actually enforce them but
I agree Mr Johnson it's it's not a
planning matter it's it's a civil matter
I suppose that's tied up to the deeds
and government poverty but yeah I'll
give way pretend but before I do I
propose that we agree the officer's
recommendation thank you thank you
councilor Luca Council second adapt
please councilor Morgan so that was
Morgan uh Council of Durham please
yeah thank you can we just go back to
the other one showing the um the parking
places I understand where councilor
White's coming from it is confusing
um can I take it that the gray areas of
Road are adopted Highway and then the
red areas are private access and then
confusingly
the yellow is actually the private roads
and parking spaces for that bottom line
of houses because it does until you sort
of get your head round that the uh the
design it does look like there's no
access to that bottom row that um as I
said it's it's unfortunate coloring but
I'm asking whether it is denoting what
is adopted Highway and what isn't
adopted Highway
there um
they're different Road types
um so the gray is um said it was a 5.5
meter road which I would expect to be
um adopted and then the red one dark
brown one is shared surface which
there's those are normally
um adopted by the highway Authority and
Friday I've got Street Lighting on them
and and then the um
yeah and these like the light brown ones
they have their private drives yep
thank you Miss Matthews uh we do we do
see that on quite a lot of the new
Estates that's fine thank you
yeah thank you Council down Castle stamp
please
oh yeah sorry
could I just come back with just another
point on on the back of what councilor
stamp said I'm wondering
um if the white Vans are banned whether
Caravans and boats on trailers also have
issues thank you okay thank you
councilor driver please
[Music]
okay
thank you chair
um I've got one uh one question and a
couple of observations the the question
uh relates to access routes for uh
school children through to either the
primary school
or the secondary school
um and whether axley there are adequate
routes through to the plume
from the site because I think that is an
issue certainly the mornings now lime
Brook Way is very busy and has increased
numbers of school pupils I'll move you
across that road in the morning the
problems we've got with traffic are just
going to get worse so whether that has
been uh thought through a little further
um my second uh point and is an
observation really is that actually it's
good to see that the fenestration looks
a lot better I have to say that Handley
Gardens and some of the houses in Hamley
Gardens uh my four-year-old nephew could
have done a better design job on some of
those those houses and were decidedly
sold it and it's good to see that some
of these are looking better than that so
I appreciate that
um my final observation really and it is
a real it does relate to conversations
we've had before and that's just about
access to infrastructure we're now six
years into this plan
and actually a lot of the infrastructure
that was promised we are still not
seeing
and that is a concern to to the
residents that actually they have bought
houses in this area and will continue to
buy houses on the promise that actually
there would be adequate infrastructure
and we're still not seeing it and thank
you Council drivers
thank you
um can I just clarify when you say
infrastructure because that does cover
quite a wide variety of things access to
sufficient School places access to
medical centers which were promised
appropriate a larger scale Road
structures that would support the growth
in numbers of people traveling thank you
um
I found that one that one first in terms
of um
um
yeah so in terms of school
infrastructure there is planned
permission for primary school over here
which I know is progressing that's with
the County Council to deliver
essentially
um and in terms of access to the plume
there are pedestrian crossings that have
been put in across the Lambert way
um hopefully everyone's using them
um which has come about because of this
development
um and I did also have that connectivity
planner
yeah so this this shows um orbit it's
not no hard to read I admit but the
greens are pedestrian Roots
um and that shows that there are links
with big existing
path Network within the town
um I might go over the the linebook way
across the crossings
um and leading into the town that way so
yes that that is that was quite
fundamental to the design
um and the design codes and the um
master plan framework which was put in
place
um when the sites were allocated as a
part of the local plan way back way back
when
um so that partly answers your first
question about accessories to schools
and
yeah so I think I think I've answered
everything and the um
well there would have been
um a financial contribution to the NHS
to provide additional Medical Services
um again that money has been secured and
no whether I don't know whether the NHS
have used the money yet
um but that that is now the provision
has been put in place for the
infrastructure
um the school hasn't been delivered yet
but it is it is coming
um but yeah there is always a time lag
and yes I um it is a common comment that
is made
um in terms of Roads road infrastructure
that has all been
um approved most of it is in place and
that's obviously in consultation with
highways Authority and based on the
capacity of existing Road Network and
um and some improvements have been made
like the junction
um
um outside morrisoned that has that has
been improved the capacity has that been
improved so that so that um so there
have been improvements made
um to increase capacity and and based on
what highways County highways were
advising that that is sufficient to see
if more development comes forward then
um more needs to come there is also a
planning permission for a relief Road
um which hasn't been delivered yet
because that's only outline permission
um Reserve flatter's
um is being worked on and will come come
forward in due course but that the money
again has been secured for the for the
county to deliver that
um but obviously that's outside oh and
there's the hour as in the district
council's hands all we can do is
um secure the money and make provision
for it and um yeah and and hand it over
that tasks over to the the county to to
deliver it so I think that answers your
question thank you yes thank you very
much Miss Matthews Council Thompson
please
a bit of a model here I'm getting
increasingly agitated sitting here
thinking about something that occurred
um I do in fact and have
free as a matter of fact
neurodiverse conditions and I do
struggle with them it's a relatively
recent idea and everybody here you try
getting to this time of life and finding
out what's been going on for the last 60
years and I find it
offensive not to say distressing that
when I hadn't uttered a word or a squeak
movement
here to referred to twice in a meeting
I'm sorry I find that really thoroughly
objectionable temperature actually does
it cancel the bill
thank you
um Mr chair and I look forward to these
schools when we've got a nationwide
shortage of 2 300 teachers and the
Colchester counselor appealing to
parents to come forward and fill some of
the vacancies so I'm very excited to see
how all these new educational
establishments are going to be stopped
but that's fine boy I can't believe I've
got to say the words climate emergency
again in this meeting we have the
current electric vehicle charging
infrastructure in the Malden District is
non-existent
and yet we're going to let a developer
developer um renege on a promise to
provide visitor charging points in my
view every new property should have
solar panels on it we can't enforce that
apparently it's too expensive for the
Developers but really to put in EV
charging points for visitor spaces we
need those and I have no problem with
this overall but I have a great big
problem with that and I'm not willing to
support this unless the EV charging
points go go forward thank you thank you
very much indeed councilor bill
thank you just one comment just to um
Ensure members are aware that so every
house will have their own
um EV charging Point yeah
um the um the discrepancy arose on
business parking spaces and that that
isn't actually required by the current
adopted vehicle parking standards so
that was um an hour on my part that that
was included when when it shouldn't have
been and so the requirement will be the
same as it was was for the or been
recommended the requirement will be the
same as phase two so
um but just to make sure that every
house does have their own vehicle
parkings on their on their own property
yeah for for their use if they choose to
so um so yeah thank you thank you
thank you very much um members thank you
very much indeed um
just quick one because thank you I'll be
the first one to come in
5.6.4 there's something in there that
does actually I did mean to bring it up
earlier and that's five
um 5.6.4 the last sentence and it says a
number three bedrooms properties 25.
um I also have a study but these rooms
are below the minimum size
recommendation to be used as a bedroom
therefore the provision of two spark
parking spaces is considered to be
sufficient how are we going to police
that so you've got 25 three-bedroom
properties I don't know if that means
there
three bedroom plus a study or their two
bedrooms plus a study but clearly that
would mean a by calling them studies
that means that the developer
um no longer needs to meet their
obligation under the parking standards
SPD to provide parking spaces so I don't
have a problem with this but how are we
going to police this are we going to go
around and say to people so you've got
to remove that bed from that study
because you don't have planning
permission for a bedroom in that study
so maybe Mr Johnson and and and and I
know you spent a long time with
enforcement perhaps you could have yeah
tell members how you're planning to
enforce that
thank you thank you chairman um
we actually did have a discussion with
the applicant on that very matter
um the
third room
um which was identified as a study as it
is now was initially larger
and could according to the ndss
standards accommodate a single bedroom a
wardrobe and the facilities that you can
find in a small
box room as we might call it we were
particularly adamant that that be
reduced in size there is a limitation to
which
um
can it even still be used yeah
I mean there are
rooms that people can use in their house
which may not meet any standards may not
even have habitable windows we can't
police using that I know these up we're
not talking about buildings that are
subject to any planning permission or
condition or anything of that of that
nature but this has been the subject of
many appeal decision on is it is it or
is it not
a habitable room or is it a study
um and we've just had to take a position
in terms of cutting through the appeal
decisions we've seen where inspectors
have said
on the one hand and being quite generous
if the developer says it's a study it's
a study why can it not be a study and
then they put it in the context of you
know covid and all the rest of it and
how work and practices have changed so
so there is that but then others have
taken a more harsh review you know if
you can get
you know a single bed and a wardrobe
here and maybe a little cupboard then it
can be occupied by a young mem a child
in a family that sort of thing
um so
this is the only view we can take in
terms of enforcement
yeah yeah they're just some things you
just can't enforce on
thanks Jim and that's that's that's very
helpful but it certainly doesn't hearten
me and and I think chairman based on
that without prejudice um withdraw my
proposal that we agree this application
because all of a sudden I think that the
parking standards document is
compromised and I I would just ask
um I can't really see the floor but can
you can you these sort of two or three
bedroom houses that we're talking about
can you expand the floor plans at all so
that we can see them
um not not
um
not not not now no I might have been
able to do anything if I'd had I can't
make that be what would be good I'd have
to do another one bigger and put it in
um so um but this is an example of the
the bedroom with the study so we've got
this upstairs you've got three uh what
two double bedrooms and one single
bedroom and then you've got this area
here which they've labeled a study which
as Mr Johnson explained when the
application originally came in was much
bigger and was was clearly big enough to
get a bed in and could be used as as a
bedroom
um so we took um the um pragmatic view
of you know that
studies are increasingly
um
popular to have at home or have space
for a study a desk some to sit
um but
but based on the national standards for
what what is the minimum size for a
bedroom as long as it's less than that
then then it will be re unreasonable to
say that that room is still could still
be a bedroom which would generate the
need for an extra parking space which is
what what we're basically talking about
because with if that study was big
enough to be a bedroom that would then
be a four bedroom house and this parking
standard say a four bedroom house needs
three spaces but a three bedroom house
only needs two spaces so that so that
was the issue
um
um but as often as we think that that is
a reasonable
um you might call it compromise but a
reasonable solution to that that problem
of providing study but what not one that
is big enough to be
um officially classed as as a bedroom
um but as Mr Johnson said you wouldn't
be able to stop somebody using it
um but if they did I it would be
um below standard and they would be
um it would be their choice for doing
that but um
uh that's that's that's the situation
and um but also just to confirm that all
these properties have at least two
spaces
um off-site on their on their own
property for parking so the only issue
is whether
um well as the plans came in originally
obviously few was that they would have
needed a third space to comply with
standard but um office of view is that
now they have reduced Society of study
sufficiently
um and it's not I think it's safe I
can't remember how how big the studies
were but it's not not like
um the the minimum standard in the
National Standard is 10 square meters
and they've shown it as nine and a half
square meters it it is no
it is um
a notably smaller smaller than it than
the minimum standard so it wasn't just
token gesture it was it was a decent um
it is significantly below the minimum
not just half a square meter below for
example so we thought that that would be
um uh acceptable or certainly not not
one that we could refuse or recommend
refuse all of the application for
um yeah thank you
Catherine Council Spencer please our
members we we're getting close to
quarter to 10 which is the time we have
to make a determination whether we agree
to continue the business uh after 10.
now we have one more item of business
after this I feel we're quite close on
this debate so I'd like to continue with
the agenda to complete the agenda this
evening with your approval
chairman can we I mean there's a
question about whether or not the final
item is withdrawn that's in the gift of
the members but can we make that
decision after we've dealt with this
application weekend counselor I just
want to put into members thinking at
this moment thank you I've got Council
Spencer next please
I only want to be very quick I just want
to say that that does sound rather like
we're aiming for the lowest standards
doesn't it rather than the high
standards
um and also doesn't it really then paint
in a very poor light the fact that the
developers stipulated that they don't
want to provide electro electric
electric charging points in the visitor
spaces
um it doesn't really feel like we're
providing for the future very well does
it it doesn't really fit with our
climate action strategy and I I
understand there are good planning
reasons why you can't even force that
but what a shame and what does it say
really about what we're doing as a
district anyway thank you chair thank
you for watching Council Spencer Council
Stevens please
thank you chair I just wanted to comment
that people convert all sorts of rooms
and cupboards I have literally seen a
boy who slept in the cupboard under the
stairs and I think that's a Harry Potter
thing but I saw it with my own eyes
people do do that and you can't stop
them they'll you know they might decide
to use the dining room as a bedroom and
you you know you that's just life I
don't think we should get too hung up on
it thank you thank you councilor Stevens
um just before we go um we actually had
a recommendation
um
uh rescinded which was a second
recommendation so the I never have to
put the officer's recommendation for
approval uh and to the chamber is there
a seconder second dude thank you Council
uh
the officer
Edition four I think it was that would
be with the amendment Amendment so this
this is so now we're putting it through
with the amendmentary yes that's quite
great
okay
so we have the recommended which has
been seconded by councilor thank you
council members those for the
recommendations do you want to agree
this person or show of hands
shower hands probably be good thank you
members I'll just give it I think they
compare let's see um past e yeah I think
Katara do you want to account on this
one there's a significant number of
hands to pass to recommend
majority is anybody against many members
uh got just for record we got three
against and one up step four against and
one abstention thank you very much in
detail thank you members members we we
are on track so with your
um permission I'd like to carry on
thank you um uh yeah my only comment on
any application is can we actually see
pieces to play to the developers and the
Agents can we see the uh illustrative
drawings please on bin day with cars
parked with bicycles because these are
idyllic where there's one car and one
bicycle and two people holding hands so
let's really show what they actually
look like and I've made that police
since I've become a member so thank you
I can't remember
yeah
we have real life we need we need we
need to give ourselves or decision
makers and members of the public the
opportunity to actually see what these
things are like because when they when
did they when they're real they're not
what they purported to be in a lot of
occasions so thank you Mr Johnson agenda
item seven and thank you very much
indeed for the people at the back of the
chamber for your patience this is a
gender writing seven which is
application two three zero zero three
two one
outm that's land west of Maple Road in
haybridge the officer presenting report
is against Miss Matthews Miss Matthews
would you be kind enough to present the
report
thank you chairman um just draw Maine's
attention to the update which includes
consultation responses from Essex County
highways and the modern um strategy team
and both objected to the application and
that has resulted in an additional
reason for refusal based on the Essex
highways objection and since the agenda
was published that the applicant has
also requested the application is
deferred
um but for the reason set out in the
update Office of the review that there
that there is no reason to delay
determinating the application
so this is an outline application with
all matters of detail reserved except
for means of access to the site for the
construction of up to up to 45 dwellings
together with Associated Garage in
parking public Urban space Landscaping
access highways drainage and
infrastructure works
so the site lies to the Western Maple
Road north of its Junction with Holloway
Road and Langford Road
and this is an aerial view which shows
the approved relief road to the north um
as part of the North haybridge Garden
suburb and the development the subject
of the um the garden suburb on the
Eastern side of Maple Road and then
you've got existing development within
settlement boundary of haybridge to the
South
this shows the site in the context of
the allocation of the garden suburb
development site within the local plan
and this shows the location of the
application site in the context of the
Strategic master plan framework
um for which covers the whole of the
North haybridge Garden suburb
um the illustrative layout
um the new vehicle access to the site
will be from Maple Road
in that position there and the existing
field access to the side of the corner
here would be converted into a
pedestrian stroke cycleway access
a parameter plan has been submitted with
an indicative surface water attenuation
proposed open space and propose Hedgerow
and and showing the existing existing
vegetation uh
and this Panda shows the location of the
grade two listed buildings which are
referred to in the report and also by
the Heritage specialist in their
consultation response
this is a plan showing the proposed
access details and there would be a need
to remove a section of Hedgerow along
Maple Road to create the access
and these are the off-site highway Works
um referred to in the report which also
formed part of Essex Highway's objection
to the proposal because that it's not
clear that they are within the um
Highway limits and therefore there's no
no guarantee that they could be actually
delivered
so got some photos here um which is
submitted as part of the application the
top view is looking from the south of
the junction of Maple Road Holloway Road
and language Road um to the north
towards the site the middle photo is a
View South along Maple Road with
application site to the right and the
bottom view is looking East
um towards the site from Langford Road
so the application has been assessed and
it's officers view it is unacceptable
particularly taking into account the
appeal decision on the previous
application and also in addition now the
highways Authority objection and
therefore it is uh recommended for
refusal for the reasons as set out in
your paper thank you thank you Ms
Matthews we have one public participant
that's the agent Mrs Kath Slater so Mrs
Slater if you care to come up to the
table thank you
foreign
appears on the screen
again the time will start from when you
start speaking thank you very much thank
you chair
we'd like to request that this
application is deferred from this
evening's meeting when this application
was submitted it was within the context
of a shortfall in the council's
five-year housing land Supply as an
acknowledgment in the Healer that the
site was a suitable for residential
development the fact that the housing
land Supply position has changed so
quickly shows just how Dynamic this
situation is we were not expecting the
application to come before committee
today and are currently preparing
additional information to further
demonstrate the sustainability of this
site in respect of reduced carbon
emissions and increase water efficiency
in addition preparations are being made
to increase affordable housing
Provisions between 47 to 50 percent so
out of a combination of 45 dwellings
that have proposed that would be around
21 to 23 dwellings and therefore would
assist in meeting the existing
affordable housing shortfall in the
district we'd very much like the
opportunity to submit this information
to the council and therefore ask members
to defer this application today to allow
for this to happen and for that
information to be considered in the
planning balance we would also like to
take this opportunity to to say that
despite the new five-year housing land
Supply position we consider the proposal
satisfies the three limbs of sustainable
development in terms of the economic
social and environmental considerations
and that these weigh in favor of the
development from a technical point of
view there are no objections that can't
be mitigated draft heads of terms for a
legal agreement have been submitted and
commit to providing contributions
towards Health recreational impact
affordable housing and the management
and maintenance of public open space
the site is well positioned adjacent to
haybridge and the garden suburbs there
are benefits from this proposal to be
weighed in the planning balance and we
request that members defer the
application to allow the submission of
this additional information that I've
referred to thank you very much for your
time thank you very much indeed Mrs
Slater
um thank you very much indeed members
we're now open the debate uh Council
Darren please well thank you very much
chairman I I appreciate the fact that
there's a request to defer it but this
Council does have some red lines
and an objection from Essex County
Council of Highways is one of those red
lines so I think that um I would propose
that we accept the officer's
recommendation and refuse to refuse this
application councilor white I got I got
Council I said
okay thank you very much indeed
councilor Durham councilor Stan chairman
can I ask what the planning officer
would would actually recommend that we
do before everybody goes against it or
the reports I know but Mr but the ladies
just said about deferment what is the
recommendations I mean did you know that
they were going to defer it or not no
yeah
you did
I did I didn't read it out but there is
um a comment in the uh in a members
update but there's not an officer's view
the the issues that the reasons for
refusal
um well the main reason for refusal
obviously uh can't be overcome through
additional information highways possibly
um and the section 106 issues could be
by submission level section 106 but the
fundamental reason which is main reason
why the appeal was dismissed previously
officers view
um is that I don't I can't see any
additional information that would change
the recommendation thank you I think
that's informative for everybody at home
watching thank you thank you very much
and I think just just to add to that
um it was also officers view that again
if members are mined to refuse this
application some of these matters which
the applicant has suggested would help
to mitigate the impact of the
development uh matters that could be
considered under appeal in terms of a
statement of Common Grounds or things of
that nature
um
yeah or advised application
um so that's why it was definitely our
view for not to support the deferral
thank you Jim thank you very much indeed
Mr Johnson we have a proposal which has
been seconded um to refuse the
application can I uh agree this by sent
members should I show our hands that's
unanimous please Tara uh members we move
on to item number eight uh any other
member any other businesses that IDM is
urgent I have none
move on to close the meeting thank you
for your contributions the meeting is
closed at 9 55 as the meeting is now
closed members revise not to enter into
any further discussion please leave the
meeting via the exit door behind the top
table and please drive or walk carefully
meeting closed at 9 59. thank you